it's free and that's why I use it I'm
living on mutt to mutts paychecks it's
not much so I cannot I can't squander
[Music]
we're always had what I thought was good
drinking the one from box springs like
six seven years ago
EPA came out said our water was
contaminated uranium and arsenic then we
shouldn't use it so they put a tag on it
saying not for human consumption
[Music]
last year my younger sister passed away
and she had I guess it's all bladder or
liver cancer and that took her in too
much she passed away it's scary to know
that she's been drinking this water for
about 18 years
I have thyroid problems my daughter
Lynette has thyroid problems we say it's
from the drinking water for some of the
people that live in this area it's like
one of the only choices since they're on
a fixed income and if you're going to
drink some water and you have no other
choice but to get water from here then
that's what you're gonna do
[Music]
I think the most worrisome part might
stay with climate change and protecting
our groundwater and securing our
groundwater having our water rights
basically
[Music]